take me back to the time when you got
the call that you're gonna be part of
this project what was that like for you
um well i
had just gotten back from uh england for
doing my screen test and it was like two
days after i got back from event and i
was sitting in my bedroom on my bedroom
floor with my mom and my agent tricked
me she was like oh i have to show you
something on zoom i was like why can't
you facetime she said no zoom zoom and i
was like okay so i open up zoom i'm
logged in and then she holds the phone
and she's like
uh sarah finn's on the phone and surf
and just goes like hey sochi are you
sitting down because i've got something
really big to tell you and i was like
yeah i'm sitting down i'm just like
welcome to the multitude no welcome to
the fc not the multiverse welcome to the
mcu you are america chavez and i just
like literally froze and i was like
what did your mom do
um she cried for sure
she was so happy for me um but i was
definitely like it took me a couple
weeks to
really sink in that i was america that
is pretty amazing it is well especially
once the emails of like well we gotta
fly you back out and start shooting i
was like okay this is actually real i
gotta start packing
you know for someone who's 14 and it's
so young with
that amount of pressure on her shoulders
you know she was incredible
and grew stronger and stronger
um
you know it was a really difficult shoot
you know with all the all the
restrictions that we had yeah
and
was it was the multi-schedule sometimes
when we were filming this all right but
i think um yeah we
we've had some fantastic times on that
yeah all right benedict i want to talk
about your character for a second you're
you're frequently trying to keep doctor
strange in line i feel like what
it's tiring
what is the dynamic like off screen when
your cameras aren't rolling are you guys
as it's pretty much the same
keeping them alive yeah yeah this is it
yeah i'm in constant therapy
um yeah it's fantastic you know we get
to
create this dynamic together
you know they are quite like the odd
couple but they definitely
they really need each other don't they
you know
strange with his new wayward powers and
wong that constantly reminding him
not to tamper with natural law because
we only defend it and
all trouble ensues and here we are yes
we are um i want to talk i've heard you
state that you'd love to appear with
nick fury even the x-men
is that who else is out there that you'd
like to get involved with all of them
all of them
everyone
yeah the films that's it uh
have portal will travel so that's very
easy for any of the writers
um
and just give me a break in between i
can't do all the movies so uh why not do
them all come on let's all do it
sochi your character i i just absolutely
love this for you your character
represents both latinx and lgbtq plus
how
first of all totally badass but how how
much does it mean to you as as such a
young person in such a monstrous sized
movie that you get to represent the best
way possible yeah um you know when i was
growing up i didn't really have too many
people to look up to um you know selena
gomez
i absolutely love dora but i mean it's
just great that i get to i mean i go i
did have a little bit of that experience
with dawn on babysitter's club and it
was just so heartwarming to have dms and
emails and stuff of people just saying
how you know with me on the screen they
felt represented and that it just meant
the world to them and it was just like
it would make me cry you know because
it's like
it's so crazy that i get to be that
person and then it's of course you know
in this
to a whole other level with marvel um
and america it's just it's really
important that people feel seen and i'm
glad i get to do it it means a ton to a
ton of people i've heard personally from
several people
my gosh yeah
um okay now we have with america joining
mcu we almost have a complete team of
young avengers would you like to see
your team up with billy tommy miss
marvel kate bishop in the future have
you made friends with anybody i have
made friends with really lots of people
yeah um and of course through ig and
stuff yeah um but i mean
why not i mean whatever they plan to do
i am willing to do it
i love it we can't wait to see what you
all do next sounds exciting we want to
see you in all the universes the two of
you okay possibilities
what was the what was the most fun thing
uh real quick just from each of you
working on this massive project i mean
this this thing sold
more pre-sale tickets this year than any
other movie in the first 24 hours fans
are freaking i saw the first 20 minutes
and i get it i'm
starving for the rest of it what's the
most fun about this thing this whole
trip for you um
and for me it was definitely creating
friendships i had amazing um
you know hair and makeup and costume and
dialect coach and of course spending
time
in cast you know it was i made some
great friendships and i will definitely
not forget that
[Music]